c'est le début des festivals à lyon
maurice béjart propose une création
mondiale baptisée lumière un ballet
dédié à barbara et jacques brel voyez ce
reportage de régis poulin et patrick
perez
je ne transforme pas mes danseurs jeu
les accouche la phrase de maurice béjart
n'a jamais été aussi concrète au
crépuscule de sa vie le chorégraphe
cherche l'origine de la lumière
naissance complexe on sait pas ce que
c'est tellement je la cherche encore
voyez c'est comme je le premier texte
que je dis c'est le teil de la bible au
dieu créé la lumière de trois jours
avant de créer de soleil ça veut dire
c'est quoi la lumière la lumière c'était
ce projecteur qui est là actuellement
dans le noir et des limiers à
fantastique et des prisonniers qui
dardait cellules fermées en vue la
lumière donc je crois que la lumière
c'est pour moi c'est l'amour c'est
l'amour des êtres et l'amour l'amour de
la vie
maurice béjart puise la lumière
intérieure de ses danseurs mais appelle
aussi ses amis brel et barbara
e
au final une minière tout en contrastes
catalogue clair obscur ou lumineuses
chorégraphie le public a déjà choisi les
spectacles affichent complet les 10-14
continue